morning everyone uh very excited to
announce our next keynote speaker Jeremy
Howard uh Jeremy Howard is in Australia
so he's not going to be joining us today
uh he's our first remote keynote speaker
and I think it's about uh 2:30 a.m. in
the morning in Australia so he's given
us a pre-recorded video uh which I hope
you enjoy but uh here is uh his rhyming
introduction
Jeremy Howard a name well known in data
Realms his Pro press has grown an
entrepreneur a researcher true and on
top of all that he's a Prof Professor
too in deep learning Realms he's known
to Aspire at fast.ai he sets hearts a
fire startups se's built success in his
stride kaggle and in litic where he did
abide an open source champ he leads the
way with Library so Grand that they here
to stay fast AI fast last core INB div
and G happppy in coding Realms he's
truly
Snappy please join me in welcoming
Jeremy um so let's start by talking
about what a language model is and so as
you might have heard before a language
model is something that knows how to
predict the next word of a sentence or
knows how to fill in the missing words
of a sentence um and we can look at an
example of one uh open AI has a language
model text of
03 uh and we can play with it by passing
in uh some words and ask it to predict
what the next words might be uh there's
a nice site called
N.D nat. letev lets us play with a
variety of language models and here I've
selected text of
vinci3 and I'll hit submit and it starts
printing stuff out the pandas were
happily playing and eating the frogs
that had fallen from the sky there an
amazing sight to see these animals
taking advantage of such a unique
opportunity the staff took quick
measures to ensure the safety of the
pandas and the frogs so there you go
that's what happened after the
extraordinary rain of live frogs at the
panda breeding facility and each time
then it'll give us a different result uh
and this is kind of
fun frogs perched on the heads of some
of the pandas it was an amazing site etc
etc Okay so so that's what a language
model
does
[Music]
um now you might
notice here it hasn't predicted pandas
it's predicted
Pand and then separately us okay after
Pand it's going to be us so it's not
always a whole word here it's
un and then harmed oh actually it's
unharmed
so you can see that it's not always
predicting words specifically what it's
doing is predicting tokens uh tokens are
either whole words or uh subword units
pieces of a word or it could even be
punctuation or numbers or so
forth um so let's have a look at how
that works so for example we can use the
actual um it's called tokenization to
create tokens from a uh from a uh from a
string we can use the same tokenizer
that um GPT uses by using tick token and
we can specifically say we want to use
the same um tokenizer that that model
text eventually dou3 uses and so for
example um when I earlier tried this uh
it talked about the Frog splashing and
so I thought we'll include they we'll
encode they are splashing and the result
is a bunch of
numbers and what those numbers are
they're basically just lookups into a
vocabulary that open AI in this case
created and if you train your own models
you you'll be automatically creating or
your code will create and if I then
decode those it's says oh these numbers
are they space are space
spool ashing and so put that all
together they are splashing so you can
see that the start of a word is with a
space before it uh is also being encoded
here
so these um language models are quite uh
neat that they can work at all um but
they're not of themselves really
designed to do anything um uh let me
explain um the basic
idea of what chat GPT gp4 B Etc are
doing um uh comes from a paper
um uh which um describes an algorithm
that I created back in 2017 called
ulmfit and Sebastian rder and I wrote a
paper up describing the ULM fit approach
which was the one that basically laid
out what everybody's doing how this
system works and the system uh has Three
Steps step one is language model
training but you'll see this is actually
from the paper we actually described it
as pre-training now what language model
pre-training does is this is the thing
which predicts the next word of a
sentence and so in the original ULM fit
paper so the algorithm I developed in
2017 then Sebastian rder and I wrote it
up in 2018 early 2018 um uh what I
originally did was I trained this
language model on Wikipedia now what
that meant is I took a neuron
Network um and a neuron network is just
a function if you don't know what it is
it's just a mathematical function that's
extremely flexible and it's got lots and
lots of parameters and initially it
can't do anything but using stochastic
gradient descent or SGD you can teach it
to do almost anything if you give it
examples and so I gave it lots of
examples of sentences from Wikipedia so
for example from the Wikipedia article
for the birds the birds is a 1963
American Natural horror horror natural
horror Thriller film produced and
directed by Alfred and then it would
stop and so then the model would have to
guess what the next word is and if
guessed Hitchcock it would be rewarded
and if it get guessed something else it
would be penalized and effectively
basically it's trying to maximize those
rewards it's trying to find a set of
weights for this function that makes it
more likely that it would predict
Hitchcock to do a good
job of solving this problem as well as
possible of guessing the next word of
sentences um the neural network is going
to have to learn a a lot of stuff about
the world it's going to
learn that there are things called
objects that there's a thing called time
that objects react to each other over
time that there are things called movies
that movies have directors that there
are people that people have names and so
forth and that that a movie director is
Alfred Hitchcock and he directed horror
films and
um so on and so forth um it's going to
have to learn an extraordinary amount if
it's going to do a really good job of
predicting the next worded
sentences now these neural networks
specifically are deep neural networks
this is deep learning and in these deep
neural networks which have um when when
I created this I think it had like a 100
million parameters nowadays they have
billions of parameters
um it's got the ability to create a rich
hierarchy of abstractions and
representations which it can build
on um and so this is really the the the
key idea
behind neural networks and language
models is that if it's going to do a
good job of being able to predict the
next word of any sentence in any
situation it's going to have to know an
awful lot about the world it's going to
know have to know about how to solve
math questions or figure out the next
move in a chess game or um uh recognize
poetry uh and so on and so forth now
nobody said it's going to do a good job
of that um so it's a lot of work to find
to create uh and train a model that is
good at that but if you can create one
that's good at that it's going to have a
lot of uh capabilities internally that
it would have to be drawing on to be
able to do this effectively so the key
idea here for me is that this is a form
of compression and this idea of the
relationship between compression and
intelligence goes back many many decades
um and the basic idea is that yeah if
you
can guess what words are coming up next
then effectively you're compressing all
that information down into a neural
network um now I said this is not useful
of itself well why do we do it well we
do it because we want to pull out those
capabilities and the way we pull out
those capabilities is we take two more
steps the second step is we do something
called language model fine tuning and in
language model fine-tuning we are no
longer just giving it all of Wikipedia
or nowadays we don't just give it all of
Wikipedia But in fact a large chunk of
the internet is fed to pre-training
these models in the fine-tuning stage we
feeded a set of documents a lot closer
to the final task that we want the model
to do um but it's still the same basic
idea it's still trying to predict the
next word of a
sentence after that we then do a final
classifier fine tuning and then the
classifier fine tuning um this is this
is the kind of end task we're trying to
get it to do now um nowadays these two
steps are very specific approaches are
taken for the step two the step B
language model fine tuning people now do
a particular kind called instruction
tuning the idea is that the task we want
most of the time to achieve is solve
problems answer questions and so in the
instruction tuning phase we use data
sets like this one this is a great data
set called open Orca created by a
fantastic uh open source group and um
and it's built on top of something
called the flan collection um and you
can see that basically
there's all kinds of different questions
in here so there four gigabytes of of
questions here are some um examples of
uh instructions I think this is from the
flan data set if I remember correctly so
for instance it could be does the
sentence in the ion age answer the
question the period of time from 12200
to 1,000 BC is known as what choice is
one yes or no and then the language
model is meant to write one or two as
appropriate for yes or no so it's still
doing language modeling so fine tuning
and pre-training are kind of the same
thing um but this is more targeted now
not just to be able to fill in the
missing parts of any document from the
internet um but to uh fill in the words
necessary to to answer questions to do
useful
things okay so that's instruction
tuning and then step three which is the
classifier fine tuning nowadays there's
generally various approaches such as
reinforcement learning from Human
feedback and others which are um uh
basically giving humans or sometimes um
more advanced models uh multiple answers
to a question such as here are some from
a a reinforcement learning from Human
feedback paper I can't remember which
one I got it from list five ideas for
how to regain enthusiasm for my career
and so the model will spit out two
possible answers or it'll have a less
good model and a more good model and
then a human or a better model will pick
um which is best um and so that's used
for the the final fine tuning
stage okay so when we talk about a
language model um where we could be
talking about something that's just been
pre-trained
something that's been fine-tuned or
something that's gone through something
like rhf uh all of those things are
generally described nowadays as language
models so my view is that if you are
going to be good at language modeling in
any way then you need to start by being
a really effective user of language
models and to be a really effective user
of language models you got to use the
best one that there is and currently
uh so what are we up to September 2023
um the best one is by far GPT 4 um this
might change um sometime in the not too
distant future but this is right now gb4
is the recommendation strong strong
recommendation now you can use
gp4 by paying 20 bucks a month to open
Ai and then you can use it a whole lot
it's very hard to to uh run out of
credits I find um now what can
gpt2 uh it's interesting and instructive
in my opinion to start with the very
common views you see on the internet or
even in Academia about what it can't do
so for example there was this paper you
might have seen GPT for can't
reason um which describes a number of uh
uh
empirical um analysis done of 25 diverse
reasoning problems and found it that
it was not able to solve them it's
utterly incapable of reasoning um
so I always find you got to be a bit
careful about reading stuff like this
because I just took the first three that
I came across in that paper and I um
gave them to
gp4 um and by the way something very
useful in gp4 is you can uh click on the
the share button um and you'll get
something that looks like like this and
this is really handy so here's an
example of something from the paper that
said gp4 can't do this Mabel's heart
rate at 9:00 a.m. was 75 beats per
minute her blood pressure at 700 p.m.
was 120 over 80 she died 11: p.m. was
she alive at noon so of course you're
human we know obviously she must be um
and gp4 says hm this appears to be a
riddle not a real inquiry into medical
conditions uh here's a summary of the
information
and
yeah sounds like mapel was alive at
noon uh so it's correct uh this was the
second one I tried from the paper that
says gp4 can't do this and I found
actually gp4 can do this um and it said
that gp4 can't do this and I found gp4
can do this now um I mentioned this to
say gp4 is probably a lot better than
you would expect if you've read all all
this um stuff on the internet about all
the dumb things that it does um almost
every time I see on the internet saying
something something that gp4 can't do I
check it and it turns out it does this
one was just last week Sally a girl has
three brothers each brother has two
sisters how many sisters does Sally have
so have to think about
it and so GPT for says Okay so is
counted as one sister by each of her
brothers if each brother has two sisters
that means there's another sister in the
picture apart from salary so Sally has
one sister again
correct
um why is it that people are claiming
that gp4 can't do these things and it
can well the reason is because I think
on the whole they are not aware of how
gp4 was
trained um GPT 4 was not trained at any
point to give correct answers uh gp4 was
trained initially to give most likely
next words and there's an awful lot of
stuff on the internet where the most
where documents are not describing
things that are true they could be
fiction they could be jokes they could
be just stupid people saying dumb stuff
um so this first stage does not
necessarily give you correct answers uh
the second stage with the instuction
tuning uh also like it's it's it's
trying to give correct answers but part
of the problem is that then in the stage
where you start asking people which
answer do they like better um people
tended to say in these uh in these
things that they prefer more confident
answers and they um often were not
people who were trained well enough to
recognize wrong answers um so so there's
lotss of reasons that the that the kind
of SGD weight updates from this process
for stuff like gp4 don't particularly or
don't entirely reward correct
answers but you can help it want to give
you correct answers if you think about
the LM pre-training what are the kinds
of things in a document that would
suggest oh this is going to be high
quality information and so you can
actually
Prime uh gp4 to give you high quality
information by giving it custom
instructions and what this does is this
is basically text that is prepended to
all of your
queries and so you say like oh you're
brilliant at reasoning so like okay
that's obviously your to Prim it to give
good answers um and then try to work
against the fact that um the the
rhf uh folks uh preferred confidence
just tell it no tell me if there might
not be a correct answer um also the way
that the text is generated is it
literally generates the next word and
then it puts all that whole lot back
into the bottle and generates the next
next word puts that all back in the
model generates the next next next word
and so
forth that means the more words
generates the more computation it can do
and so I literally I tell it that right
and so I say first spend a few sentences
explaining background context
Etc so this uh custom
instruction um allows it to solve um
more challenging
problems and you can see the
difference here's what it uh looks like
for example if I say how do I get a
count of rows grouped by value and
pandas and it just gives me a whole lot
of information which is actually it
thinking so I just skip over it and then
it gives me the answer and actually in
my
uh
um custom instructions I actually say if
the request begins with
VV actually make it as concise as
possible and so it kind of goes into
brief mode and here is brief mode how do
I get the group this is the same thing
but with VV at the start and it just
spits it out now in this case it's a
really simple question so it didn't need
time to think so hopefully that gives
you a sense of how to get language
models to give good answers uh you have
to help them and if you if it's not
working it might be user error basically
uh but having said that um there's
plenty of stuff that language models
like gp4 can't do
um one thing to think carefully about
is does it know about itself can you ask
it what is your context length how were
you trained what Transformer
architecture you're based
on at any one of these stages did it
have the opportunity to learn any of
those things well obviously not at the
pre-training stage nothing on the
internet existed during GPT 4's training
saying how gp4 was trained
right uh properly Ditto in the
instruction tuning properly dito in the
rhf so in general you can't ask for
example a language model about itself
now again because of the rlf it'll want
to make you happy by giving you
opinionated answers so it'll just spit
out the most likely thing it thinks with
great
confidence this is just a general kind
of hallucination right so hallucinations
is just this idea that the language
model wants to complete the sentence and
it wants to do it in an opinionated way
that's likely to make people
happy um it doesn't know anything about
URLs um it really hasn't seen many at
all I think a lot of them if not all of
them pretty much were stripped out um so
if you ask it anything about like what's
at this web page again it'll generally
just make it up um and it doesn't know
at least gp4 doesn't know anything after
September 2021
um because the um information it was
pre-trained on uh was from that time
period September 2021 and before called
the knowledge cut
off okay now uh something else super
helpful um that you can use is what they
call uh Advanced Data
analysis um in Advanced Data
analysis in Advanced Data analysis you
can um ask it to basically write code
for you uh and we're going to look at
how to implement this from scratch
ourself quite soon um but first of all
let's learn how to use it so uh I was
trying to build something that split uh
into markdown headings a document on
third level markdown headings so that's
uh three hashes at the start of a line
um and I was doing it on the whole of
Wikipedia uh so using regular
Expressions was really slow so I said oh
I want to split this up
and it said okay here's some code which
is great because then I can say Okay
test it and include edge
cases and so it
then puts in the code creates ex cases
tests
it and it says yep it's
working um however I just discovered
it's not I noticed it's actually
removing the carriage return at the end
of each sentence so I said oh fix that
and update your
tests so it said okay um so now it's
changed the test update the test cases
let's run them and oh it's not working
so it says oh yeah fix the issue in the
test
cases no they didn't work and you can
see it's quite clever the way it's
trying to fix it by looking at the
results and but as you can see it's not
every one of these is another attempt
another attempt another attempt until
eventually I gave up waiting and it's so
funny each time it's like debuging again
okay this time I got to handle it
properly and I gave up at the point
where it's like oh one more attempt so
it didn't solve it um interestingly
enough and you know I I again it's it
it's there's some limits to the amount
of kind of logic that it can do this is
really a very simple question question I
asked it to do for me and so hopefully
you can see you can't
expect even gp4 code interpreter or
Advanced Data analysis it's now called
to make it so you don't have to write
code anymore you know it's not a
substitute for having programmers um
so why would you use the open AI API
rather than chat GPT because you can do
it programmatically so you can um you
know you can analyze data sets you can
do repetitive stuff um uh it it's kind
of like a different way of programming
you know it's it's things that you can
think of
describing um but let's just look at the
most simple example of what that looks
like so if you pip install open aai uh
then you can import chat chat completion
and then you can say Okay chat
completion. create using GPT 3.52 turbo
and then you can pass in a system
message this is basically the same as
custom instructions so okay you're an
auss llm that uses Aussie slang and
analogies wherever
possible okay and so you can see I'm
passing in an array here of messages so
the first is the system message and then
the user message which is what is
money okay so GPT 3.5 returns a big
embedded uh
dictionary um and
uh the message content is well M money
is like the oil that keeps the Machinery
of our economy running
smoothly there you go just like aquala
loves its eucalyptus leaves we humans
can't survive without this stuff so
there's the Aussie lm's view of what is
money now what happens when we are this
is really important to understand when
we have a
followup in the same conversation
how does that work so we just asked what
goat means so for example Michael Jordan
is often referred to as the goat for his
exceptional skills and
accomplishments and Elvis and The
Beatles referred to as goat due to their
profound influence and achievement so I
could
say what profound influence and
achievements are you referring ref in
to okay well I meant Elvis Presley and
the Beatles did all these things now how
does that work how does this followup
work well what happens is the entire
conversation is passed back and so we
can actually do that here so here is the
same system prompt here is the same
question right and then the answer comes
back with role assistant and I'm going
to do something pretty cheeky
I'm going to pretend that it didn't say
money is like oil I'm going to say oh
you actually said money is like
kangaroos I thought what what it's going
to do okay so you can like literally
invent a conversation in which the
language model said something different
um because this is actually how it's
done in a multi-stage conversation
there's no state right there's nothing
stored on the server you're passing back
the entire conversation again and
telling it what it told you right so I'm
going to tell it it's it told me that
money is like kangaroos and then I'll
ask the user oh really in what way and
this is kind of cool because you can
like see how it
convinces you of of something I just
invented oh let me break it down for you
cobba just like kangaroos hop around and
carry their joys in their pouch money is
a means of carrying value around so
there you go it's uh make your own
analogy so what else can we do
well let's create our own code
interpreter that runs inside
Jupiter um and so to do this um we're
going to take advantage of a really
Nifty thing uh called um function
calling um which is provided by the open
Ai apaa and in function calling when we
call our ask GPT function which is this
little one here we had room to pass in
some keyword arguments that will be just
passed along to chat completion. creat
and one of those keyword arguments you
can pass
is functions what an earth is that
functions
tells open AI about tools that you have
about functions that you have so for
example I created a really simple
function called
sums and it
adds two
things in fact it adds two ins
um and I am going to pass that function
to chat completion. create now you can't
pass a python function directly you
actually have to pass What's called the
Json schema um so you have to pass the
schema for the function um so I created
this Nifty little function that you're
welcome to borrow um which uses
pantic uh um and also Python's inspect
module to automatically take a python
function and return the schema for it
and so this is actually what's going to
get pass to open AI so it's going to
know that there's a function called sums
it's going to know what it does and it's
going to know what parameters it
takes uh what the defaults are and
what's
required so this is like when I first
heard about this I found this a bit
mindbending because this is is so
different to how we normally program
computers where the key thing for
programming the computer here actually
is the doc string this is the thing that
gp4 will look at and say oh what does
this function do so it's critical that
this describes exactly what the function
does and so if I then
say
um what is 6+
3 right and I just I really wanted to
make sure it actually did it here so I
gave it lots of prompts to say because
obviously it knows how to do it itself
without calling sums um so it'll only
use your functions if it feels it needs
to um which is a weird concept I mean I
guess feels is not a great word to use
but you kind of have to anthropomorphize
these things a little bit because they
don't behave like normal computer
programs um so if I if I ask GPT what is
6 + 3 and tell it that there's a
function called sums then it does not
actually return the number n instead it
returns something saying please call a
function call this function and pass it
these arguments so if I print it out
there's the
arguments and so if I now say okay call
the function that we got back we finally
get
nine so this is a very simple example
it's not really doing anything that
useful but what we could do now is we
can create a much more powerful
function
called
Python and the python
function
executes
code using
Python and Returns the
result so
now I can say ask GPT what is 12
factorial system prompt you can use
Python for any required computations and
say okay here's a function you've got
available it's the python
function so if I now call
this it will pass me back again a
completion object and here it's going to
say okay I want you to call python
passing in this
argument and when I do it's going to go
import math result equals blah and then
return result do I want to do that yes
say
do and there it
is now um there's one more step which we
can optionally do I mean we've got the
answer we wanted but often we want the
answer in more of a chat format and so
the way to do that is to again repeat
everything that you've passed into so
far but then instead of adding
an assistant role response we have to
provide a function Ro response and
simply
put in here the result we got back from
the function and if we do
that we now get the pros response 12
factorial is equal to 479 million
1,600 now
functions like python you can still ask
it about non-python
things uh and it just ignores it if you
don't need it right so you can have a
whole bunch of functions available that
you've built to do whatever you need uh
for the stuff which
um the language model isn't familiar
with um and it'll
still solve whatever it can on its own
and use your tools use your functions um
where
possible okay so we have built our
own code interpreter from scratch I
think that's pretty
amazing so that is um what you can do
with uh or some of the stuff you can do
with uh open
AI um what about stuff that you can do
on your own
computer so then what we're going to be
using is a library called Transformers
from hugging face and the reason for
that is that basically people upload
um lots of pre-trained models or F
trained models up to the hugging face
Hub and in fact there's even a
leaderboard where you can see which are
the best
models um all right so you can find
models to try out from things like this
leaderboard um and there's also a really
great leaderboard called fast eval which
I like a lot um because it focuses on
some more sophisticated uh eval
valuation method such as this Chain of
Thought evaluation method um so I kind
of trust these a little bit more um and
these are also gsmk is a difficult math
benchmark uh big bench hard um so forth
so yeah so you know stable bler 2 Wizard
math 13B dolphin L 13B Etc these would
all be good
options um yeah so you need to pick a
model
and at the moment nearly all the good
models are based on
metas llama 2 so when I say based on
what does that mean well what that means
is this model here llama 2 7B so it's a
llama model that's that's just the name
meta called it this is their version two
of llama this is their seven billion
size one it's the smallest one that they
make and specifically these weights have
been created for hugging face so you can
do it with the hugging face
Transformers and this model has only got
As far as here it's done the language
model for pre-training it's done none of
the instruction tuning and none of the
rlf um so we would need to find tune it
to really get it to do much
useful um so we can just say Okay create
a automatically create the appropriate
model for language model so cause or LM
is B basically refers to that ULM fit
stage one
process um or stage two in fact so get
the pre-train model from this name metal
lama lama 2 blah blah
okay now
um generally speaking we use um 16bit
floating Point numbers
nowadays um but if you think about it 16
bit is two byes so 7B * 2 it's going to
be 14
gabt uh just to load in the weights um
so you've got to have a decent model to
be able to do that um perhaps
surprisingly you can actually just cast
it to 8bit and it still works pretty
well thanks to something called
discretization so uh let's try that so
remember this is just a language model
look can only complete sentences we
can't ask it a question and expect a
great answer so let's just give it the
start of a sent Jeremy how it is
a and so we need the right tokenizer so
this will automatically create the right
kind of tokenizer for this model we can
grab the tokens as
pytorch here they
are
um
and just to confirm if we decode them
back again we get back the original plus
a special token to say this is the start
of a
document and so we can now call generate
so generate
will um autor regressively so call the
model again and again passing its
previous result back as the next um as
the next input um and I'm just going to
do that 15 times so this is you can you
can write this for Loop yourself this
isn't doing anything fancy in fact I
would recommend writing this yourself um
to make sure that you know how that it
all works
okay um we have to put those tokens on
the GPU and at the end I recommend
putting them back onto the CPU the
result and here are the tokens not very
interesting so we have to decode them
using the tokenizer and so the first 25
sorry first 15 tokens are Jeremy Howard
isar 28y old Australian AI researcher
and entrepreneur okay well 28 years old
is not exactly correct but we'll call it
close enough I like that thank you very
much llama 7B So Okay so we've got a
language model completing
sentences um it
took one and A3
seconds um and that's a bit slower than
it could be because we used 8bit if we
use 16bit there's a special thing called
B float 16 which is a really great 16bit
uh floating Point format that's use
usable on any somewhat recent GP Nvidia
GPU now if we use it it's going to take
twice as much RAM as we discussed but
look at the
time it's come down to 390
milliseconds um now there is a better
option still than even that there's a
different kind of discretization called
gptq where um a model is carefully
optimized to work with uh four or eight
or other you know lower Precision data
um
automatically
and um
this particular person known as the
bloke uh uh is fantastic at taking
popular models running that optimization
process and then uploading the results
back to huging
fist so we can use this gptq
version um and internally this is
actually going to use I'm not sure
exactly how many bits this particular
one is I think it's probably going to be
four
bits but it's going to be much more
optimized um and so look at this 270
seconds it's actually
faster than 16bit even though internally
it's actually casting it up to 16 bit
each layer to do it that's because
there's a lot less memory moving
around and to confirm uh in fact what we
could even do now is we could go up to
13B easy and in fact it's still faster
than the 7B now that we're using the
gptq version so this is a really helpful
tip so let's put all those things
together the tokenizer the generate the
batd code we'll call this gen for
Generate and so we can now use the 13B
gptq
model and let's try this Jeremy Howard
is a so it's got to 50 tokens so fast
16year veteran a Silicon Valley
co-founder of kagle a Marketplace
predictive model his company kaggle.com
has become the data science competitions
what I don't know what I was going to
say but anyway it's on the right track I
was actually there for 10 years not 16
but that's all right
um okay so this is looking good
um but probably a lot of the time we're
going to be interested in you know
asking questions or using instructions
so stability AI has this nice series
called stable Beluga including a small
7B one and other bigger
ones um and these are all based on llama
2 but these have been instruction tuned
uh they might even have been rlh I can't
remember now um so we can create a
stable Beluga
model and now something really
important that I keep forgetting
everybody keeps forgetting is during the
instruction tuning
process during the instruction tuning
process the instructions that
are passed in actually
are um
uh they don't just appear like this they
actually always are in a particular
format and the format Believe It or Not
changes quite a bit from from fine-tune
to fine tune and so you have to go to
the web page for the
model and scroll down to find out what
the prompt format is so here's the
prompt format so I generally just copy
it and then I paste it into python
and created a function called make
prompt that use the exact same format
that it said to use and so now if I want
to say who is Jeremy Howard I can call
Jen again that was that function I
created up here and make the correct
prompt from that
question and then it returns back okay
so you can see here all this prefix this
is a system instruction
this is my question and then the
assistant says Jeremy Howard's an
Australian entrepreneur computer
scientist co-founder of machine learning
and deep Learning Company fast at AI
okay this one's actually all correct so
it's getting better by using an actual
instruction tune
model um and so we could then start to
scale up so we could use a 13B and in
fact uh we looked briefly at this open
Orca data set earlier so llama two has
been fine- tuned on OK Orca and then
also fine- tuned on another really great
data set called
platypus and so the whole thing together
is the open Orca platypus and then this
is going to be the bigger 1B gptq means
it's going to be
quantized so that's got a different
format okay a different prompt format so
again we can scroll down and see what
the prompt format is there it
is okay
and
so we can create a function called make
open Orca prompt that has that prompt
format and so now we can say okay who is
Jeremy Howard well now I've become
British which is kind of true I was born
in England but I moved to
Australia uh professional poker player
no I'm definitely not that uh
co-founding several
companies including fast. AI also kaggle
okay so not bad it was acquired by
Google was it 2017 probably something
around there okay so you can see we've
got our own models giving us some pretty
good
information
um how do we make it even better you
know because it's it's it's still
hallucinating you know
um and you know llama 2 I think has been
trained with more up-to-date information
than GPT 4 it doesn't have the September
2021 cut off um but it you know it's
still got a knowledge cut off you know
we would like to be able to use the most
upto-date information we want to use the
right information to answer these
questions as well as
possible so to do this we can use
something called retrieval augmented
generation so what happens with um
retrieval augmented generation
is when we take the question we've been
asked like um who is J H and then we say
okay let's try and search
for documents that may help us answer
that
question um so obviously we would expect
for example Wikipedia to be useful and
then what we do is we say okay with that
information um let's now see if we can
tell the language model about what we
found and then have it answer the
question
um so let me show you so let's actually
grab a
Wikipedia um uh python package um we
will scrape Wikipedia grabbing the
Jeremy Howard web page uh and so here's
the start of the Jeremy Howard Wikipedia
page um it has 613 words now generally
speaking these open source models will
have a context length of about 2,000 or
4,000 so the context length is how many
tokens Can it handle so that's fine
it'll be able to handle this web page
and what we're going to do is we're
going to ask it the question so we're
going to have here question and with a
question but before it we're going to
say answer the question with the help of
the context we're going to provide this
to the language model and we're going to
say context and we're going to have the
whole web page so suddenly now our
question's going to be a lot bigger our
prompt right so our
prompt now
contains the entire web page the whole
Wikipedia page followed by a
question and so
now it says Jeremy how is an Australian
data scientist Ed entrepreneur an
educator known for his work in deep
learning co-founder of fast AI teaches
courses develops software conducts
research used to be yeah okay it's
perfect right so it's actually done a
really good job like if somebody asked
me to send them a
you know 100w
bio uh that would actually probably be
better than I would have written myself
and you'll see even though I asked for
300 tokens it actually got sent back the
end of stream token and so it knows to
stop at this point
um well that's all very well but how do
we know to pass in the Jeremy Howard
Wikipedia page well the way we know
which Wikipedia page to pass in
is that we can use another model to tell
us which web page or which document is
the most useful for answering a
question and the way we do that is we we
can use something called sentence
Transformer and we can use a special
kind of model that's specifically
designed to take a document and turn it
into a bunch of
activations where two documents that are
similar will have similar activations so
let me just let me show you what I mean
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
grab just the first paragraph of my
Wikipedia page and I'm going to grab the
first paragraph of Tony Blair's
Wikipedia page okay so we're pretty
different people right this is just like
a really simple small example and I'm
going to then call this model I'm going
to say encode and I'm going to encode my
Wikipedia first paragraph Tony Blair's
first paragraph
and the
question which was um who is Jeremy
Howard and it's going to pass back a 384
long
Vector of embeddings for the question
for me and for Tony Blair and what I can
now do is I can calculate the
similarity between the question and the
Jeremy Howard Wikipedia page and I can
also do it for the question versus the
Tony Blair Wikipedia page and as you can
see it's higher for me and so that tells
you that if you're trying to figure out
what document to use to help you answer
this question better off using the
Jeremy Howard Wikipedia page than the
Tony Blair Wikipedia
page so if you had a few hundred
documents you were thinking of using to
give back to the model as context to
help it answer a question
you could literally just pass them all
through to encode go through each one
one at a time and see which is
closest um when you've got thousands or
millions of
documents you can use something called a
vector database uh where basically as a
one-off thing you go through and you um
encode all of your documents and so in
fact um there's there's lots of
pre-built systems for this um here's an
example of one called H2O
GPT um and this is just something that
I've got um uh that I've got running
here on my computer it's just an open
source thing written in Python and it's
sitting here running on Port 7860 and so
I've just gone to Local Host
7860 um and what I did was I just uh
uploaded I just clicked upload and last
uploaded a bunch of papers in fact I
might be able to see it better yeah
there we go a bunch of
papers and so you know we could look
at
uh can we search yeah I can so for
example we can look at the ULM fit paper
that uh sir Brer and I did and you can
see it's turn taken the PDF and turned
it into slightly crappily a text format
and then it's created an embedding for
each you know each section so so I could
then um ask it you know what is ULM
fit and I'll hit
enter and you can see here it's now
actually saying based on the information
provided in the context so it's showing
us it's been given some context what
context did it get so here are the
things that it
found right so it's being sent this
context so this is kind of citation
uh goal ofm fit proves the performance
by leveraging the knowledge and adapting
it to the specific task at hand
um
how does youm
fit improve
performance or maybe I should
say what techniques be more
specific does ULM
fit uh let's see how it
goes okay there we go so here's the
three steps pre-train fine tune fine
tune cool um so you can see it's not bad
right um it's
not amazing like you know the context in
this particular case is pretty
small um and it's and in particular if
you think about how that embedding thing
worked you can't really use like the
normal kind of followup so for example
now the problem is that there's no
context here being sent to the embedding
model so it's actually going to have no
idea I'm talking about ULM fit so
generally speaking it's going to do a
terrible
job yeah see it say it's used as a
Roberta model but it's not but if I look
at the sources it's no longer actually
referring to Howard and Rudder so anyway
you can see the basic idea this is
called retrieval augmented generation
R um and it's a it's a Nifty approach
but you have to do it with with some
care so finally I want to talk about
what's perhaps the most interesting um
uh option we have which is to do our own
fine tuning and fine-tuning is cool
because rather than just retrieving
documents which might have useful
context we can actually change our model
to behave based on the documents that we
have avail able I'm going to show you a
really interesting example of fine
tuning here um what we're going to do is
we're going to fine tune using this um
nosql data set and it's got
examples of like a a a schema for a
table in a
database a
question and then the answer
is the correct
SQL to solve that question using that
database schema and so I'm hoping we
could use this to create a um you know a
kind of be could be a handy use handy
tool for for business users where they
type some English question and SQL
generated uh for them automatically
don't know if it actually work in
practice or not but this is just a
little fun idea I thought we'd try out
um I know there's lots of
startups and stuff out there trying to
do this more seriously um but this is
this is quite cool because I actually
got it working today in just a couple of
hours so what we do is we um use the
hugging face data sets um library and
what that does just like the hugging
face Hub has lots of models stored on it
hugging face data sets has lots of data
sets stored on it and so instead of
using Transformers which is what we used
to grab models we use data sets and we
just pass in the name of the person and
the name of their repo and it grabs the
data set and so we can take a look at it
and it just has a training
set with
features and so then I
can have a look at the training set so
here's an example which looks a bit like
what we've just seen so what we do now
is we want to find tun a model now we
can do that in in a notebook from
scratch takes I don't know 100 or so
lines of code it's not too much but
given the time constraints here um and
also like I thought why not why don't we
just use something that's ready to go um
so for example there's something called
Axel which is quite nice in my
opinion here it is here love another
very nice open source piece of software
and uh again you can just pip install it
and it's got things like gptq and 16 bit
and so forth ready to go um and so what
I did was
I um it basically has a whole bunch of
examples of things that it already knows
how to do it's got llama 2 example so I
copied the Llama 2 example and I created
a SQL example so basically just told it
this is the path to the data set that I
want this is the
typee um and everything else pretty much
I left the
same uh and then I just ran this command
which is from their read me accelerate
launch axo passed in my yaml and that
took about an hour um on my GPU and at
the end of the hour it had created a q
Laura out directory uh Q stands for
quantise that's because I was creating a
smaller quanti po model uh Laura I'm not
going to talk about today but Laura is a
very cool thing that basically another
thing that makes your models smaller and
also handles um can use bigger models on
smaller gpus for
training um
so uh I trained
it and then I thought okay let's uh
create our own one so we're going to
have this
context and
um this
question get the count of competition
hosts by
theme and I'm not going to pass it an
answer so I just ignore that um so again
I found out what prompt uh they were
using um and created a SQL prompt
function and so here's what I'm going to
do use the following contextual
information to answer the
question uh context create table so
that's the context text question list or
competition host sorted in ascending
order and then
I tokenized that called
generate
and the answer was select count hosts
comma theme from Farm competition Group
by theme that is correct so I think
that's pretty remarkable we have just
built you know so took like an hour to
figure out how to do it and then an hour
to actually do the
training um and at the end of that we've
actually got something which which is
converting um Pros into SQL based on a
schema so I think that's that's a really
exciting idea okay
so as you can see um there's a lot of
stuff that you can do right now um with
language models um particularly if you
feel pretty comfortable as a python
programmer um I think it's a really
exciting time to get involved in some
ways it's a frustrating time to get
involved because
um you know it's very early and a lot of
stuff has weird little edge cases and
was tricky to install and stuff like
that you know people are still figuring
things out as we go um but I think it's
an exciting time to be doing this stuff
and I'm yeah I'm really enjoying it and
I hope that this has given some of you a
useful starting point on your own
Journey so I hope you found this useful
thanks for listening
[Applause]
bye